americans are willing to take pay cuts
to never go back into the office again
this is a bloomberg story a new survey
shows that many americans say they'd be
willing to take reduced salaries
give up days off or put in more hours
for a job that offers a fully
remote
option a fully remote option here are
some of the numbers the vast majority of
people well over 65 percent said they
wouldn't give up more than five percent
all right so that's sort of the majority
says five percent that's it but then you
have 15 percent of respondents of the
survey said they'd be willing to shave
off
25 percent of their salary to be fully
remote let me give you some numbers
basically so if you make 50 grand a year
quick math 2 500 bucks so now you're
making 47 500 bucks right
but if you're making
um if you're taking 25 percent of that
50 grand you're giving up 12 500 bucks
now you're making only 37 500. but now
you're fully
remote let me do some other numbers
right here let's say you're making a
hundred grand a year you're giving up
five percent how much is that dave i'm
not going with numbers he's not a
numbers guy all right it's uh five grand
five grand five percent of five
five percent of a hundred thousand so
now you're making 95 grand nothing crazy
get to work remote but if you're making
a hundred grand and you're one of the 15
percent of respondents who says they'll
give up 25 you're making how much now
okay
david's here for his production skills
for his witty banter and for his great
looks and amazing dance moves not so
much because you're a numbers guy not a
numbers game okay paul are you a numbers
guy i am a numbers guy all right great
so you would have done that math very
easily yep those are all right so the
basic that's it all right here here's uh
here's some more numbers for you nearly
half now 46 percent of respondents said
they would give up a quarter of their
days off
to work fully remote and here's that 15
again 15 they would give up all their
paid time off to be able to work from
home so what is this telling you this is
telling you that basically a nice chunk
or even you know a smaller sliver are
basically saying look we'll do anything
just make us
not
don't we don't want to go back into the
office again please take my money take
my money
take my free time just don't make me go
back into the office so here's the
here's the question for you guys at home
please leave some comments over here and
obviously my friends here david paul and
the person the female that should be
named renee lemus
how much would it take
for you
to just never have to go in the office
let's a hypothetical question david
let's say you make 50 grand a year how
much of a pay cut would you take to say
all right i'm just working from home
that's forever that's assuming that i i
want to work from home so i was working
from home last year okay it's isolating
kind of boring played a lot of video
games i mentioned in the last podcast
that's true now i'm in the office you
know i hang out with people here
you're not one of these people you're
saying i'm not trying to give up anybody
i like coming into the office coming to
the office fair enough socialize paul do
you have a different perspective than
david uh i do not have a different
perspective i've actually again i've
worked from home myself yeah and i
actually feel the same way like i could
actually have the option to work from
home and i choose to be here i really
love coming to office okay although
sometimes i do wish i was alone but
ultimately i really
enjoy being in the office and being
around people okay cool um yeah what a
young lady how about you
um i'm pretty indifferent from working
from home or in the office but i
wouldn't take a pay cut to work from
home so now let's say you're making 50
grand you wouldn't take 45 grand or 47
make 47 and never have to go in the
office
no okay
well let us know in the comments over
there what you think how much of a pay
cut you would take well so i mean just
to give you an example 15 of people said
that they would take
a 25 pay reduction to never have to go
back in the office so if you're making a
hundred grand right you're a hundred
grand you're a six figure earner
congratulations you're willing to go
down to 75k a year to basically be like
that's it see you when i see you i
wouldn't want to be yeah i'm not going
to the office
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken